>> Kate: MITCH MARNER PICKED UP
AN ASSIST ON KADRI'S 20TH. HE IS
NOW THE LEAGUE LEADER AMONG
ROOKIES WITH 39 POINTS. MARNER
ALSO HAS A TEAM-HIGH 12
MULTI-POINT GAMES THIS SEASON.
TORONTO'S ROOKIES HAVE 175
POINTS SO FAR THIS YEAR,
THAT IS THE MOST IN THE
NHL. WELCOME TO SPORTSCENTRE,
EVERYONE. KATE ALONGSIDE
NATASHA. SO UNFORTUNATELY FOR
THE FLAMES, I MEAN, THEY LOOKED
LIKE THEY HAD A LITTLE MOMENTUM
AS OF LATE, AND NOW THEY JUST
LOOK LIKE THEY'RE REELING ONCE
AGAIN. ON THE FLIP SIDE, THOUGH,
TORONTO SNAPPING THEIR MINI
SLIDE, AND GOOD FOR THEM TO PICK
UP A MONSTER WIN AT HOME BECAUSE
WE KNOW THEY'RE GREAT ON THE
ROAD BUT THEY HAVE STRUGGLED AT
TIMES AT THE AIR CANADA CENTRE.
>> YEAH, THEY LOOKED REALLY GOOD
ON MONDAY. AND LIKE YOU
MENTIONED, CALGARY ALL OF A
SUDDEN REELING. THEY LOOSE 7-3
TO THE OILERS ON SATURDAY AND
THEN GET SHUT OUT A GAME LATER.
SO NOT MUCH GOING RIGHT FOR THEM
LATELY. WITH MUCH MORE ON
THIS ONE HERE IS GLENN SCHIILER
AND THE PANEL.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALONGSIDE DAVE POULIN,
JEFF O'NEILL AND
BOB MACKENZIE. WELL, MUCH LIKE
HIS TEAM, WHAT A DIFFERENCE A
YEAR MAKES FOR NAZEM KADRI.
REMEMBER THAT STRETCH LAST YEAR
AT THE BEGINNING, ONE GOAL IN
19 GAMES, JUST SNAKE PIT.
NOW JEFF, HE'S UP TO 20 GOALS,
HIS SHOTS FINDING THE BACK
OF THE NET.
>> YEAH, GLENN, HE'S REALLY
BECOME A COMPLETE PLAYER FOR THE
TORONTO MAPLE LEAFS. HE'S DOING
IT AT ALL ENDS OF THE RINK, ALL
DIFFERENT PHASES OF THE HOCKEY
GAME. AND TONIGHT I-- AS SOON AS
I GAVE HIM PROPS FOR SCORING IN
TIGHT AND NOT SHOOTING FROM
OUTSIDE THE DOTS, HE SCORES TWO
WRIST SHOT GOALS. WHAT A SEASON
TO HAVE 20 IN THE BANK RIGHT
NOW. WITH A LOT OF HOCKEY
GAMES LEFT, YOU KNOW THE REST
IS JUST GRAVY, GLENN. THERE'S NO
REASON WHY CAN'T GET 30, 35
GOALS THIS YEAR FOR THE LEAFS.
>> MEANWHILE, YOU DON'T OFTEN
SEE JOHNNY HOCKEY GET CAUGHT
WITH A BODY CHECK, BUT HE TOOK
A LICKING A COUPLE OF TIMES THIS
GAME. THE BIG ONE OF COURSE, LEO
KOMAROV RUNNING HIM OVER. THE
FLAMES WANTED A HEADSHOT. BOB,
HOW DO YOU THINK
THE LEAGUE WILL REVIEW THIS?
>> WELL, MY ESTEEMED PANEL
COLLEAGUE HERE, JEFF O'NEILL,
SAID RIGHT AWAY AS SOON AS IT
HAPPENED, THAT WAS A CLEAN
BUT VIOLENT HIT,
AND I'D BE VERY SURPRISED
IF THE LEAGUE SAW IT ANY OTHER
WAY THAN THAT. IT WAS NOT LATE,
IT WAS NOT A CHARGE, IT WAS NOT
AN ELBOW, THERE WAS NO LAUNCHING
INVOLVED. NOW, WAS THERE CONTACT
TO THE HEAD? ABSOLUTELY, THERE
WAS. BUT I BELIEVE THE LEAGUE
WOULD SAY THIS IS UNAVOIDABLE
CONTACT TO THE HEAD. A TALLER
PLAYER ON A SMALLER PLAYER.
THERE WAS BODY ON BODY CONTACT.
THE HEAD CONTACT WAS INCIDENTAL,
AND WHILE IT WAS A VERY VIOLENT
HIT, AND IT LOOKED FOR A MOMENT
AS IF JOHNNY GAUDREAU MIGHT BE
OUT OF THE HOCKEY GAME,
AND THE FACT THAT HE CAME BACK
WAS A REAL POSITIVE, I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'LL BE ANY
SUPPLEMENTARY DISCIPLINE. AND AS
WE POINTED OUT DURING THE GAME,
NO PENALTY CALL ON THE PLAY. SO
THE REFS APPEAR TO HAVE GOTTEN
IT RIGHT AND I SUSPECT THE
LEAGUE WILL ENDORSE THAT CALL--
NON-CALL BY THE REFEREES.